bonsoir madame merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france bruno le maire qui
confirme donc aujourd'hui qu'une taxe
sur les géants du numérique sera bien
appliquée en 2020 c'est une bonne chose
pour vous êtes satisfaite
moi je suis pour tout ce qui peut
freiner
amazon tout ce qu'il peut stopper
l'impunité d'amazon mais cette taxe sur
le numérique elle est complètement
indifférent insuffisante
en fait juste votre reportage était très
bien et montrer à quel point en fait on
a des entre une entreprise comme amazon
qui se permet de piétiner la démocratie
en respectant pas les droits des
salariés à s'organiser qui se permet
comme le vous l'avez dit le magazine va
et ça vient de le révéler d'espionner
aussi les mouvements sociaux les
syndicats nous il ya quelques semaines
on avait envoyé une lettre à jeff bezos
son parlement européen qui était signée
par 37 parlementaires
suite à la diffusion d'offres d'emploi
dans lesquelles amazon indiqué chercher
à recruter des analystes en europe pour
espionner les syndicalistes les
travailleurs et les political leaders et
les leaders politiques et donc je crois
que maintenant la fronde qui monte
contre amazon en fait en france mais pas
que elle montre que ça suffit de cette
impunité
on est dans une période de crise où tout
le monde doit prendre ses
responsabilités ou voilà on met tous un
masque extrêmement de gens devant un
nombre extrêmement important de gens ont
perdu beaucoup avec les conséquences
sociales de la crise sanitaire et vous
avez des entreprises comme amazon qui se
gavent depuis le début de la pandémie et
qui en plus de se gaver de perdre ne
prennent même pas leurs responsabilités
et se permettent de piétiner les lois ne
pas payer leurs impôts
1 et donc quand j'entends parler de la
taxe évidemment la taxe sur les gars
femmes évidemment ce serait une bonne
chose mais d'abord est ce qu'on voudrait
pas commencé par demander amazon qui
s'égarent vais depuis le début de la
crise de payer une taxe exceptionnelle 1
et que cette taxe exceptionnelle
les fonds pourraient être utilisés par
exemple à subvenir aux besoins des
petits commerces qui eux pâtissent
d'amazon ça c'est une solution à très
court terme mais c'est pas ça qui
résoudra le problème d'un
la zone à qui il faut faire comprendre
que ces gens là que jeff bezos
personne n'a élus qui n'est pas le roi
du monde et par exemple je pense qu'il
ya une autre chose sur lequel le
gouvernement devrait se pencher et peut
se pencher s'est stoppée faire un
moratoire comme s'est demandée par les
amis de la terre par attaques sur les
projets d'entrepôts amazon il ya une
vingtaine de projets d'entrepôts amazon
qui sont prévues en france 1
et ces projets là ils nuisent à
l'environnement
ils font que bah vous avez 500 camions
par jour qui vont passer
il se garde d'argent public parce qu'ils
utilisent des routes des infrastructures
qui sont payés par l'argent public
et en plus pour des emplois qui sont des
emplois de d'extrêmement de mauvaise
qualité et qu'ils vont détruire d'autres
emplois deux fois plus au minimum que ce
qu'il voit ancré dans l'économie dans
l'économie réelle c'est des petits
commerçants qui doit fermer la halle à
leur porte
etc etc mais il avait tout de même tout
de même je ne veux bien que
effectivement amazon soit l'objet de
toutes les critiques est ce que c'est
bien la faute d' amazon si les petits
commerces ont été fermés et que le
simple consommateur a effectivement fait
appel
amazon dans une période où c'était
effectivement très compliqué d'aller
faire ses courses en termes de coville
est ce que ce sont eux les principaux
coupables tout comme ne pas avoir été
taxé pendant pendant des années
finalement est ce que il faut en vouloir
à l'entreprise où l'on se trompe de
coupables dans cette affaire alors
d'avoir dans ce que je voudrais relever
dans ce que vous dites vous avez raison
de d'indiquer le rôle du consommateur
moi j'en ai un peu ras le bol
moi je ne suis pas pour culpabiliser le
consommateur parce que je comprends que
quand les fins de mois sont difficiles
et bien quand on a un produit qui va
coûter 20 % - sur amazon on a eu la
chance sur amazon parce qu en fait un
réseau de 98% des produits que vous
allez acheter sur la zone euro de la tva
donc ça fait qu'ils ont les moyens de
vendre des produits 20 % de moins qu'en
en plus de ça ben le gouvernement a
décidé que les commerçants étaient
fermés que les librairies été fermée que
tous les produits dits non essentiels
vous pouvez même pas y accéder dans les
supermarchés on déroule un tapis rouge
amazon et vous verrez
de dire que le couple s'est évidemment
si amazon est dans cette situation il
utilise des lois même si souvent il est
piétine mais s'il n'y avait pas un
gouvernement qui leur dérouler le tapis
rouge
ça se passerait pas comme ça donc
évidemment que on a les moyens
politiques
en fait en stoppant les entrepôts amazon
en les faisant payer en les forçant à
payer des impôts parce qu'il est hors de
question si vous voulez que le
commerçant là dont on a fermé les portes
ces dernières semaines il paye un peu
moins de 30 % d'impôt 1 amazon va payer
moins de 5 % d'impôt parce qu'ils vont à
utiliser le dumping fiscal qui existe en
europe le fait qu'il ya des états comme
le luxembourg ou payer moins de 5 %
d'impôts ils vont faire fuiter leur
chiffre d'affaires à l'étranger dans ces
paradis fiscaux en déclarant un bénéfice
beaucoup moins que ce qu'il aurait dû
être en france et donc vous voyez en ce
moment on se rend compte depuis le début
de la crise à quel point on a besoin
d'avoir des hôpitaux des services
publics
eh bien figurez-vous que l'argent
d'amazon ne serait-ce que ces attaques
qui faisait le calcul la fraude à la tva
chez amazon ça représente chaque année
1,5 milliard d'euros 1,5 milliard
d'euros c'est le montant du déficit de
l'hôpital public donc amazones du vol en
fait hamas c'est amazon c'est aussi
c'est peut-être parfois ça explique
peut-être en partie l'attitude peut-être
du gouvernement s'est aussi des dizaines
de milliers les centaines de milliers
d'emplois en france amazon qui cherche
manifestement recruter 37 mille
personnes dont notamment déjà parfois
des jeunes en difficulté quand même
est-ce que vous pouvez leur accorder ce
crédit là alors ça c'est l'argument
quand vous regardez moi j'ai organisé
les auditions de travailleurs d'amazon
de toute l'europe et des états unis
aussi on a le même discours partout
qu'on va revoir par compte un projet
d'entrepôt s'installe dans différentes
régions de france ils vont s'installer
dans des endroits qui sont sinistrés
industriellement où il ya des
entreprises qui ont fermé où il ya un
fort taux de chômage
en arrivant avec l'argument de dire on
arrive on va créer des emplois
eh bien d'abord il faut regarder au
niveau de fin de la qualité de cet
endroit ce sont des endroits extrêmement
précaire et surtout surtout amazon
détruit plus d'emplois
qui n'en crée un rapport qui n'est pas
la france d'un soumise mais qui est de
quelqu'un qui est député à la ruelle qui
s'appelle moudir mahjoubi qui dans un
rapport a indiqué que a calculé qu
amazon pour un emploi créé et cher va
zone c 200 emplois détruits par ailleurs
et en plus on estime que ce taux est
largement sous-estimée et ensuite le
modèle d'amazon fonctionne sur la
prédation
on vous pourrez dire vous savez on a
beaucoup entendu ces derniers temps
l'amazone les communicants d'amazon dire
on rend service aux commerçants parce
que les commerçants peuvent qui ont
fermé leurs portes peuvent vendre des
produits sur amazon
en fait quand on regarde c'est moins 5%
des entreprises qui sont sur la
marketplace d'amazon qui sont des pme
françaises
la majorité étant des boîtes chinoise
parce que le modèle d'amazon qui vous
dit je vais faire l'intermédiaire
et c'est là où c'est vraiment dangereux
le plus pervers on en parle rarement
c'est qu'en fait par exemple vous avez
une entreprise qui va vendre du liquide
vaisselle à la phrase et au citron
elle passe par l'amc est prise amazon
amazon va collecter les données va
savoir
en regardant que et devant plus de
liquide vaisselle à la fraise que du
liquide vaisselle au citron et va
décider ensuite de récupérer ces données
et de concurrencer le vendeur de liquide
vaisselle en vendant lui même amazon du
liquide vaisselle à la fraise et après
avec les privilèges qui sont qu'ils ont
accès qui sont propriétaire de la plate
forme donc ils ont des avantages en
matière logistique et à terme qu'est ce
qui se passe
le vendeur de liquide vaisselle qui
étaient passés par cet intermédiaire
amazon et détruit se fait laminer par la
concurrence d'amazon qui a une visée
monopolistique de tout manger tout ce
qui est autour de lui pour arriver à
avoir le monopole
merci en tout cas les il a jailli
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france nous avoir apporté votre point de
vue merci à vous